es ist wieder soweit Tradition wollen
schließlich gepflegt sein gerade jetzt
in der Weihnachtszeit dazu gehört dass
man über die Feiertage liebe Menschen
besucht beziehungsweise wenn Sie mit der
Bahn reisen dass man versucht liebe
Menschen zu besuchen ja
das wird ja immer mehr zum Abenteuer in
diesen Tagen ich sag mal so im Advent
stranden am Bahnhof haben Westfalen da
lernt man Weihnachten und
Gewaltfantasien schließen sich gar nicht
aus ja man ist inzwischen Kummer gewohnt
da werden Sie mir zustimmen aber diesen
Herbst und Winter schießt die Bahn echt
den Vogel ab in Norddeutschland hatte
eine Störung den gesamten Fernverkehr
und auch Teile des Regionalverkehrs
lahmgelegt der ganze Strecken sind
gesperrt und pendler müssen umsteigen
nicht drei sondern 60 und mehr Minuten
später kamen viele Züge diese Woche in
Nordrhein-Westfalen für drei Stunden
hatte die Bahn alle Signale auf halt
gestellt also wenn ich Geld habe ich
mein Auto kaufen
ja warum nicht warum nicht für den
Ticketpreis Hamburg München kriegst du
auch ein gebrauchten Polo sage ich mal
gut da kam in den letzten Wochen
natürlich auch viel Pech zusammen auf
den antiken Gleisen Tatsache ist wir
müssen dringend viel mehr in die Bahn
investieren da gibt es eigentlich keine
zwei Meinungen außer in der Ampel wo sie
gefühlt nur noch streiten oder nur noch
aktuell kloppen sich hier FDP
Verkehrsminister Wissing und
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke und zwar
um dieses Thema im Etat 2023 ist aber
wieder deutlich mehr Geld für die Straße
vorgesehen als für die Schiene müssten
sie nicht eigentlich jetzt alle Mittel
zusammen kratzen und sie in die Bahn
stecken
nein ach so
tja schade schade er Zoff Ursache ist
übrigens das neue
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz dass sie
eines Bauvorhaben beschleunigen soll ist
eine gute Sache allerdings will die FDP
damit auch den Neubau von Autobahn
beschleunigen und da kommt den Grünen
natürlich direkt der dinkelkuchen hoch
ist ja klar
worauf wiederum Volker Wissing antwortet
das sei aber alles im Einklang mit dem
Ampel Koalitionsvertrag ist das so ja
wenn der Volker das sagt gut lässt sich
ja schnell überprüfen gucken wir mal
kurz rein in die Ampel
Gebrauchsanweisung da heißt es
beschleunigt werden sollen bevorzugt
systemrelevante Bahnstrecken
Stromtrassen und Ingenieurs Bauwerke
also kaputte Brücken
Brücken reparieren ja neue Autobahn
erstmal nein weil und tatsächlich haben
wir das dichteste Straßennetz Europas
das könnte man ja mal richtig gründlich
sanieren auch für den Warenverkehr und
den Rest komplett in die stecken aber
nicht mit der fdp-freunde dem besten
Freund des Autos auf keinen Fall ja
meine
es ist ja fast pathologisch wirklich
Autoerotik ist ja nicht falsch jetzt
argumentieren die beiden gibt
gummi-fetischisten hier ernsthaft sie
sagen bald fahren ja nur noch E-Autos
auf den Autobahn und dann könnte man ja
auch neue bauen was ist denn das schief
gelaufen in der Kindheit in meiner
Familie gibt es sogar die Legende meinen
erstes Wort sei Auto gewesen
oh wie süß oder Auto noch vor Mama toll
toll sein zweites Wort war übrigens
umsatzsteuerrückerstattung aber
das nur am Rande am Dienstag letzten
Dienstag mussten Wissing und seine grüne
Kollegin bei Olaf Scholz zum
Krisengespräch antreten Ergebnis sie
streiten weiter natürlich dabei sind wir
uns doch einig deutschland braucht
endlich eine menschenwürdige Bahn wie
zivilisiertes Land da ist immer noch
Technik aus der Kaiserzeit im Einsatz
wirklich weichen die der Kaiser
eingeweiht hat experten sprechen von 50
bis 100 Milliarden Investitionsstau nur
bei den Schienen nur bei den Schienen
winziges Lichtlein am Ende des
einsturzgefährdeten Tunnels für ihr
wahrscheinlich drängen ist das Problem
hat die Bahn jetzt endlich die Lösung
und Bahn Bistro da gibt's jetzt Tee und
Kaffee auch aus Porzellan Tassen
dass ich das noch erleben darf meine
Damen und Herren ja endlich kann man ab
Verspätung Stunde drei in echtes
porzellanweiden bis 2030 sollen doppelt
so viele Menschen mit dem Zug fahren ich
habe ein gutes Gefühl meine Damen und
Herren in diesem Winter wer Sonne
Werbung hier ehrlicher nach der BahnCard
25 50 und 100 kommt jetzt endlich die
Bahncard Street die Bahn 2.0 endlich auf
der Straße für alle die zur Abwechslung
auch mal ankommen wollen in einem
geräumigen Abteil das nur nach dir
selber riecht garantierter Sitzplatz
keiner hockt auf dem Boden und der
Hammer die Klimaanlage funktioniert nie
wieder kaputtes zugklo einfach anhalten
und laufen lassen die Bahncard Street
und speziell für Studenten unterzubis
die Bahncard Feed immer noch eher am
Ziel als die Bahn
[Musik]
die Bahncard sieht hole ich dir
meine
natürlich ist Bahnfahren trotzdem
klimafreundlicher als Autofahren logisch
selbst unter diesen Umständen und es
gibt sie ja die guten Nachrichten zur
Wahl die Stadt Herten zum Beispiel
60.000 Einwohner hat seit Sonntag wieder
einen eigenen Bahnhof nach nur 40 Jahren
Wartezeit toll oder ja ja man kann jetzt
wieder mit dem Zug nach Herten bis jetzt
gar nicht warum aber
es geht und die Kollegin dieser Flagge
steht für uns an der Bahnstrecke
Oldenburg Wilhelmshaven wo in diesen
Tagen Geschichte geschrieben wird ich
glaube das ist nicht übertrieben dieser
nein Oliver passiert wirklich
historisches ich gehe sogar so weit zu
behaupten mit der Strecke Oldenburg
Wilhelmshaven schafft die Deutsche Bahn
endgültig den Sprung in 20 Jahrhundert
sie meines 21 nein ich meine das
zwanzigste die kriegen jetzt sogar Strom
der neue heiße Scheiß Strom Oberleitung
ist nach Hammer Erfindung es ist ein Tag
zum Feiern in Oldenburg denn endlich ist
die Bahnstrecke zwischen Oldenburg und
Wilhelmshaven elektrifiziert
da kann man ruhig auch übers Volk sein
unfassbare 70 Kilometer wurden in nur 16
Jahren zweigleisig ausgebaut und
elektrifiziert für gerade mal 1,3
Milliarden Euro
gut geplant waren ursprünglich nur 22
Millionen aber
schon ja ja
Strom der Wissing redet doch immer von
Digitalisierung
immer langsam mit den jungen ja eins
nach dem anderen Freundchen nur 54% des
gesamten deutschen Schienennetzes haben
Strom auf dem Rest fährt die gute alte
Diesellok zum Vergleich die Schweiz hat
100% die blöden Streber Heidis aber ist
so eine Katastrophe warum brauchen wir
für alles so lange oh Olli war das jetzt
wirklich schwer zu erklären wir
investieren pro Kopf viel weniger in die
Schiene als Österreich
Schweden Norwegen und alle anderen aber
komm wird jetzt alles besser verspricht
der Wissing sie haben doch eben selber
gesagt Oliver konzentrieren wir uns
endlich mal auf die guten Nachrichten
alles wird insofern anders als die als
bisher denn die Scheiben der älteren zu
Generation lassen die Neo
den also alles anders als die schreiben
älterer zu Generationen lassen die im
Neo Mobilfunk durch und verbessern so
den Empfang im Zug ganz erheblich
also
irgendwas mit Scheiben ist jetzt besser
im übrigen unterwissing werden die
Maronen Strecken wenigstens mal saniert
seine Vorgänger diese CSU Dödel haben
alles vergammeln lassen und jeden neuen
bayerisches draußen gesteckt warte mal
warte mal ich glaube da hinten kommt ein
Zug wie aufregend elektrisch
beschissene Dampflok
auf Gleis 3 erhält ein Fahrt der Dampf
ICE an die scheuer
du scheiße dieser Flagge meine Damen und
Herren vielen Dank und dann ist dann
natürlich noch der Mann der persönlich
für alles verantwortlich ist was 2022 so
unerträglich macht Vladimir
bombardierovic Putin da ist ein
Vollpfosten noch zu viel der Ehre finde
ich passender wäre der Reisegutschein
nach Den Haag einfache Fahrt
inzwischen wirkt der Kriegsverbrecher
wenn man darauf achtet fast ein wenig
beleidigt weil die Ukraine sich partout
nicht von ihm erobern lassen das macht
ihm aber nichts im kremme wird trotzdem
schon mal angestoßen in Moskau feiert
der russische Präsident mit seinem
Militär
jetzt gibt es viel Gerede im Westen
wegen unserer Luftschläge auf die
Energieversorgung unseres Nachbarlandes
ja wir machen das
und da könnt ihr aber wer hat denn
angefangen
ich weiß es ich weiß es du warst das ja
ey das lief im Fernsehen das hat die
ganze Welt gesehen Putin serviert im
Kreml also eine gute Flasche Fiesling
trocken
meine Damen und Herren viele viele
halten ihn immer noch für einen
Politiker das ist ein Gangster Freunde
Chef einer kriminellen Vereinigung die
den Rohstoffreichtum Russlands abzockt
während die russische Bevölkerung immer
ärmer wird und damit die nicht aufmuckt
führte halt Krieg und verwandelt
Russland endgültig in ein Nordkorea 2.0
er ist ja so ja
jede Art von Opposition abgeschafft bzw
im Arbeitslager und im russischen
Fernsehen läuft rund um die Uhr nur noch
Propaganda unter anderem die Wahrheit
über Olaf Scholz ja sein Großvater war
ein hochrangiger SS-General der zweimal
gegen Russland kämpfte
sieht ja aus wie Hitler auf jeden Fall
Schnurrbart und Gestik
er bewegt sogar seine Hand wie er und
ihm fehlt eindeutig nur noch der
Schnauzer
es ist keine Überraschung das Scholz
lächelt wenn er das Wort Genozid hört
na deutsche japanse ja sehr gut ja
Panzer Vorsicht kulturelle Aneignung
Freunde aber schon interessante Theorie
sind Olaf Scholz und Adolf Hitler
möglicherweise ein und dieselbe Person
ich stelle nur Fragen meine wir lachen
aber vielleicht ist Putins Propaganda da
einer großen Sache auf der Spur wie
konnten wir nur alles so blind sein
[Musik]
die Ampel scheinbar ein weltoffenes
Modernisierungsprojekt doch sie haben
uns alle getäuscht in Wirklichkeit sind
das durch die Bank Nazis der russische
Geheimdienst hat jetzt wasserdichte
Beweise erfunden 17 Regierungsmitglieder
die Quersumme ist 8 also schon wieder
Hitler einer der Minister heißt ganz
offen Hubertus Heil ebenfalls mit dabei
Svenja Schulze Initialen SS Zufall ihre
Parteichefin ist die geflüchtete sa skia
esgen die Farben der Ampel sind rot gelb
und grün aber wenn man die mischt genau
braun und jetzt kommt der eigentliche
Hammer der reichsfinanzminister liebt
Hunde genau wie Hitler sonst noch
parallelen denke ich an Autobahn
Autobahn Autobahn
keine weiteren Fragen
Vladimir Putin lässt jetzt gezielt die
Strom und Wärmeversorgung der Ukraine
angreifen täglich um eine humanitäre
Katastrophe auszulösen moralisch kann
man kaum tiefer sinken warum hat der
Mann trotzdem immer noch Fans warum auch
bei uns in Deutschland ich sag nur
Alternative für Russland oder wie die
heißen ja die AFD entblödet sich nicht
Putins narrativ von durch die NATO
erzwungene Notwehr Einmarsch ins
Nachbarland zu verbreiten oder in den
Worten von Bernd höcke des besten
deutschen fäkalpoeten ich möchte
unseren Kopf aus dem Hintern des
US-amerikanischen hegemons hinausziehen
ja sie hörten die analther native für
Deutschland
und die steht in Umfragen wieder richtig
guter richtig gut wie immer wenn Krise
ist und daran wird auch der gerade
aufgeflogene umsturzplan der
Reichsbürger nichts ändern tatsächlich
verbreiten höcke und Co ganz ähnliche
verschwörungsmythen wie die und eine
ehemalige afd-abgeordnete war als Prinz
Heinrich Justizministerin vorgesehen es
ist so bizar werde alles mit putschen
wollte zum Beispiel der pensionierte KSK
Oberst Maximilian Eder ja als
als neuer sagen wir mal wer macht Chef
zuständig für den militärischen Teil des
Umsturzes bei dem die Liquidierung
störrischer Gegner ausdrücklich
vorgesehen war was hat er denn für ein
Problem mit unserer Demokratie es gibt
also Politiker die am Wochenende und
dann möglicherweise während der Woche
manchmal nichts anderes zu tun haben
weil solche satanischer Rituale
durchzuführen am kleinen Kindern oder
ein junge Frauen
festhalten
Öl ja Höhlen ich glaube die Höhle
zwischen seinen Ohren hat sehr viel Echo
ja ich bin kein Arzt aber ich fürchte
Meister Eder hat in seiner aktiven Zeit
so viel Panzer Abgase eingegangen jetzt
jetzt ist es immer leicht sich über irre
wie ihn lustig zu machen aber
tatsächlich wollten die diesen Staat
beseitigen knapp 100 Waffen wurden
gefunden außerdem lange feindeslisten
geschrieben von wenn man sich die
Mehrheit der möchte anguckt von Rentnern
ja ja die meisten sind tatsächlich
Rentner gut wenn man das weiß geht es
natürlich Möglichkeiten die beim
nächsten reichstagssturm zu stoppen
einfach weg mit den barrierefreien
randbahnen Eingang ne ja natürlich so
müssen die putschssenioren nämlich die
ganzen Stufen hoch da fallen schon mal
die meisten aus dann bauen wir zur
Ablenkung noch ein Ententeich mit
besonders süßen Enden super bequem
Bänken und Brot zum Füttern direkt
daneben gibt André Rieu 24 Stunden
gratis Konzerte und um die alten
Verfassungsfeinde endgültig loszuwerden
braucht es nur noch ein Angebot eine
Busreise nach St Petersburg für nur 33
reichsmarkt Butterkuchen inklusive
ich muss bekloppt sein
wir wollen es wirklich nicht
vernietlichen gut dass es die Razzia gab
ich meine daran ist nichts niedlich die
alten radikalisieren sich also ein
kleiner Teil der alten überlegen Sie mal
eine
75-jährige Frau sitzt gerade in U-Haft
weil sie mit Komplizen geplant hatte
Karl Lauterbach aus einer Talkshow zu
entführen
also quasi aus seinem Zuhause ne was ist
denn los hier früher zu meiner Zeit
haben Omas einfach Plätzchen gebacken
und jetzt hätten die Umsturzpläne aus
oder wollen unseren stark hallo sind wir
live also Ulrich von Heesen und ich
haben soeben das ZDF Sendezentrum in
Mainz besetzt wir nennen uns das
Kommando Cookie Dent und sagen Schluss
mit dem Jugendwahn ganz genau ab sofort
geht wieder das ZDF Programm in den
Grenzen von 1971 Moment ich rolle mal
eben den Intendanten Weg der Vogel hat
hier nichts mehr zu melden wir waren
selbst total überrascht wie leicht man
hier reinkommt das ZDF ist schlecht der
gesichert als der Bundestag da sitzt
nachts nur ein uralter
Moment haben sie einen Ausweis nein
aber wir haben
edle Tropfen in Nuss
so und jetzt wird hier ein anderer Wind
es kann noch nicht sein dass ein
heute-show-moderator von gerade mal 56
Jahren also nach ZDF Maßstäben ein Kind
entscheidet wer den goldenen Volk
Pfosten kriegt das machen jetzt wir und
unser erster Kandidat ist der deutsche
Fußball und zwar nicht wegen
irgendwelcher One Love binden sondern
weil wir keine Verteidiger mehr haben
ganz genau früher wussten wir noch wie
mein Gerät das Erfolgsgeheimnis des
deutschen Fußballs war in zwei Worten
zusammengefasst nackte Gewalt
Kannibalismus Schmerzen und zwar beim
Gegner damals dürfte man Bundesliga erst
ab 18 gucken wegen dem ganzen Blut und
der vielen Eingeweide aber rausgeflogen
sind weil die Spanier gegen Japan
verloren haben dafür gibt es von uns den
vielen Dank für gar nichts ihr
Arschgesicht der Pfosten
so direkt nächste Fasten in unserem
Alter hat man nicht mehr viel Zeit
Preisträger ist die Stadt Berlin wo
jetzt die Wahl wiederholt werden muss
wegen zu wenig Wahlzettel nur
geschätzter Ergebnisse und allgemeiner
Unfähigkeit wegen Berlin halt umso
lustiger im Nachhinein dieser Spot ich
komme aus voller Überzeugung zurück nach
Hause mit einem starken Zukunftsprogramm
bauen Bildung beste Wirtschaft
bärenstarke Verwaltung
ausdenken und dafür gibt es den der
Berliner Bär gibt endgültig auf und
bläst sich das Hirn raus Fasten hoch
verdient so nächster Preisträger die
Ampel doch doch weil sie es nicht
schafft die einzige klimaschutzmaßnahme
einzuführen die nichts kostet das
Tempolimit Begründung dafür hätten wir
nicht genug Verkehrsschilder so Moment
es gibt aber tatsächlich neue Studien
die beweisen wie gefährlich zu langsam
fahren ist
unterhalb einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit
fängt der Fahrer an vor Langeweile
andere Sachen zu machen einfache
laubzüge Arbeiten zum Beispiel oder
Aquarelle malen wieder andere machen
sich die Fußnägel das ist
unverantwortlich so und einen haben wir
noch ne den Häuptling Winnetou wird
verboten und muss zum Jobcenter Pfosten
für die mit Abstand bekloppteste Debatte
des Jahres wow mein Bruder weder die
Karl maybücher noch die Filme wollte
irgendwer verbieten trotzdem
wochenlanger Aufregung vor allem an den
bayerischen Lagerfeuern hier zum
Beispiel bei Häuptling weiche Birne
diejenigen die kaum und Indianer Spulen
es werden diejenigen die Feuerwehr
und deshalb sage ich ganz klar Mani
Tourette uns naja begrabt sein Hirn an
der Biegung des Flusses
das ZDF zeigt doch weiter wie eine tu
und jetzt wo wir den Sender
kontrollieren läuft in einer
Endlosschleife sogar nur noch der
Klassiker Winnetou und das Halbblut
abanacci nichts anderes mehr so was
hätte heute gar nicht mehr gedreht das
war noch Filme die sind Natur
[Musik]
die Ironie wird ihnen nicht entgangen
sein ausgerechnet jetzt wo wir weniger
heizen sollen ist der Dezember nach
langer Zeit mal wieder so richtig kalt
oder als als wäre es Winter es ist
unglaublich winterlich ja immer noch
eine völlig neue Erfahrung für uns das
ganze Konzept Energie sparen es mussten
wir ja nie irgendwas kam aus der Leitung
und war super billig dass uns seit
Jahren Nachbarländer vor zu viel
Abhängigkeit von Herrn Putin gewarnt
haben das war allen egal also nicht in
der Politik das war buchstäblich allen
egal tja und jetzt meckert die
Netzagentur schon wieder weil wir zu
viel gasverballern wir heizen ganz
normal weiter es wäre egal was die
kostet denn
frieren auf keinen Fall ich möchte nicht
dass er friert ich möchte nicht dass
unsere Haustiere frieren und ändern kann
ich sowieso nicht um es mit den Worten
des berühmten russischen Märchens zu
sagen friert euch mal die Schwänze ab
Unverschämtheit und sexistisch warum
soll nur die Männer frieren
ja meine klar jeder guckt in diesen
Tagen auf seinen Zähler und denkt nur
noch Kilowatt the [ __ ] ist hier denn los
ne da kommt der Spardruck von ganz
alleine und man kann ja zwischendurch
schon sparen also weder Kinder sollen
frieren noch die Hamster aber man kann
schon sparen und zwar mit diesem
wie heißt das Trainings noch dass uns
der eine nette Opa neulich erklärt hat
nachts wenn alle schlafen wird die
Heizung runtergefahren das kann jede und
jeder an seine Heizung selbst einstellen
und wem das zu kompliziert ist einfach
Form ins Bett gehen den Thermostat
drunter drehen
ach so
deswegen auch die Zahlen da drauf ja
aber Moment in welche Richtung drehst
denn morgens wieder hoch
in dieselbe ja Winfried Kretschmann war
übrigens früher sie werden es nicht
glauben Lehrer aber man merkt es kaum
noch finde ich und
vielleicht vielen Dankbarkeit dank Winni
dem schwäbischen Erklärbär wissen wir
seit diesem Jahr endlich wie ein
Waschlappen funktioniert
immer zu Hause liegen ich wusste nie für
was aber war wahrscheinlich alles gut
gemeint auch die Politik sollten wir
immer bedenken steht vor völlig neuen
Herausforderungen in diesem energiekrieg
und am härtesten trifft das Robert habe
Weg Wirtschaftsminister war mal ein
Traumberuf jetzt ist es sowas wie die
Mutter aller arschkarten ja ja während
Anna-Lena baerbock immer beliebter wurde
ist der arme Robert in den Umfragen
zwischenzeitlich brutal abgestürzt und
das hinterlässt natürlich Spuren auch
Nerlich der grüne Wirtschaftsminister
Robert habe ist genervt der zuständige
Energieminister konnte hat am Abend
leicht genervt sie gehen offensichtlich
davon aus dass wir Atomkraftwerke wie
Licht an und ausmachen wollen
muss weg sind wir denn hier im
Fußballstadion oder was habe ich auch
mehrfach erläutert das hätten sie
eigentlich auch wissen müssen ja was die
Frage im Moment komme ich nicht mehr
dazu Brötchen einzukaufen und
geschweige denn morgens in Ruhe zu
frühstücken es tut mir herzlich leid
sie hat gut lachen als Außenministerin
da schüttest du im Ausland Hände sag's
irgendwas über Wert und fließt wieder
nach Hause das ist es Harbeck musste
sich derweil ganz Umlagen ausdenken und
sie dann direkt wieder wegschmeißen also
scheiße war oder unter Zeitdruck
Gaspreis Bremsen hinten ganz schnell
natürlich macht man da auch Fehler indem
man zum Beispiel im Shopping rauscht mit
deutschem Geld den Gaspreis für ganz
Europa hochtreibt es mussten eben rasch
Erfolgsmeldungen her und volle Speicher
gute Stichwort allein am letzten Montag
haben wir in Deutschland einen
Prozentpunkt unseres kompletten
gasvorratsverbalert kann so nicht
weitergehen diese Krise ändert einfach
alles sogar unser dating verhalten
[Musik]
du bist Single frierst und singst dich
nach jemandem für den Nebenkosten kein
Problem sind
energiepartner.de die dating Plattform
mit der du endlich den Traumtypen
findest der sich eine warme Wohnung
leisten kann und zwar so warm wie immer
du willst mit Fußbodenheizung boah er
hat einfach alles sogar elektrisches
Licht
aus deiner Nachbarschaft wollen dir
einheizen haben wir jetzt Sex oder
Energiepartner
denn warm ist das neue sexy
extrem verstörende Bilder
wir müssen halt Energie sparen alle
müssen sparen die Bürger und eigentlich
auch der Staat wenn ich mir die
Haushaltslage so angucke umso
erstaunlicher dass die Ampel sich
tatsächlich einen ziemlich aufgeblähten
personalapparat gönnt überlegen Sie mal
16 Minister das ist Rekord 37
parlamentarische Staatssekretäre Rekord
und jetzt kommt 42 sogenannte
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung
Weltrekord gab es noch nie die haben da
wirklich mittlerweile für jedes Thema
einen eigenen beauftragten von
Tierschutz bis keine Ahnung
Spreewaldgurken ist der Wahnsinn und wir
schalten mal live rüber nach Berlin zu
einer beauftragten Betriebsfeier im
Kanzleramt wo Matthias Matschke gerade
frisch ernannt wurde zum was jetzt genau
ja gute Frage ich bin eben berufen
worden zum Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für die Belange der
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung wir
brauchen dringend eine
Interessensvertretung auch um uns
abzugrenzen von den bundesbeauftrag die
vom Parlament bestimmt werden wir vom
Kabinett zwei paar Schuhe wir sind
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung die sind
Bundesbeauftragte die hassen wir
Arschlöcher Prost Leute ja Prost aber
ich meine immer mehr beauftragte ist das
denn das richtige Signal an die Bürger
in diesen Tagen absolut die Ampel hat
hier ein kleines Jobwunder geschaffen
nennen Sie mir doch mal eine Branche die
in dieser Krise einen solchen
Stellenzuwachs hat wir sind quasi
Deutschlands letzter Wachstumsmarkt ja
wie schön also wenn manche Jobs wie
sagen wir mal ostbeauftragter die machen
ja Sinn auch für den Laien aber Cem
Özdemir hat z.B fürs
Landwirtschaftsministerium jetzt einen
neuen Tierschutzbeauftragten ernannt
obwohl es in seinem Haus längst eine
ganze Abteilung für Tierschutz gibt ja
was denn die können sich das ja
aufteilen dann vertritt der eine die
Interessen von Katzen und der andere ja
keine Ahnung was Würmer Watt weiß ich
22 Millionen Euro allein dieses Jahr nur
für euch 42 beauftragte plus Büros plus
eure Mitarbeiter wenn ihr neue Regierung
kommt werden die Posten nie wieder
abgeschafft dafür kommen jedes Mal neue
dazu ohne das gesetzlich geregelt wäre
was ihr eigentlich genau macht wissen
wir auch nicht aber jeder einzelne von
uns wird dringend gebraucht ich
jedenfalls möchte nicht in einer Welt
leben ohne den bundeswahlbeauftragten
für sozialversicherungswahlen oder die
Beauftragte für den Berlin Umzug und
Bonn Ausgleich oder war das Bonn Auszug
und Berlin ungleich egal so eine
Regierung muss halt auch ihre Leute
versorgen und Themen brauchen Gesichter
und zwar sexy Gesichter auf uns
rund die Hälfte von euch sind
Abgeordnete die kontrollieren also die
Regierung für die sie selber arbeiten na
und wir sind doch multitaskingfähig die
FDP zum Beispiel ist Regierung und
Opposition gleichzeitig so Leute Schluss
mit dem genagel ich bin stolz und froh
euch heute zwei tolle neue Kollegen
vorstellen zu dürfen einmal der
Beauftragte für Bundes Bademeister
Belange
unendlich der Beauftragte für Karnevals
und faschingsangelegenheiten Prinzip
[Applaus]
Matthias Matschke vielen Dank
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper
abonniere endlich den verkackten heute
schon Kanal also geht doch